[Music]
james kicks off this hour in salt lake
city james welcome to the ramsay show
hey how are you guys we're doing great
how can we help
hey so i've got a question on student
loan debt so
my wife and i have been paying off uh
we're on baby step two we've paid off
about 27 thousand dollars in 18 months
thanks
sorry um so it's been an emotional
journey since the current administration
put the pause on student loan debt we've
taken all that stuff since we're
debt-free except for student loans and
we've been dropping into savings we've
got about ten thousand dollars and since
things are starting back up we're
wondering should we dump all of that
into it or save a little bit kind of
like baby step three
so you're saying can i can i skip and
leap frog to baby step three while i'm
still paying off the student loans
yeah when they paused the interest and
everything my wife and i gauged out the
risk of the potential
of them doing the 50 000 forgiveness and
if we were dumping everything into it
it'd be a loss whereas right now since
there's no interest we're putting into
savings so that way if it didn't get
wiped out we could just put all that
into the student loans how much do you
guys have left james
thirty seven thousand
okay well um
you may not like our answer
james uh i would
i know it's okay i mean i feel like you
knew it a little bit but here's what i'm
gonna tell you
i would not bank on the government to
forgive your student loans whether it's
10 or 50 000 i want you to take control
there's a level of mojo that you get
back when you decide you know what i'm
going to handle this thing
i can get out of this and i don't need
anyone's help other than my own work
ethic my own sacrifice to do this so
you've got ten thousand dollars saved
you have thirty seven thousand dollars
left in debt correct
correct okay so if you wanna do things
the ramsey way and i don't say that
because i'm a ramsey man i say because
it's the proven way that people have
gotten out of debt the people that you
hear on these debt-free screams so what
that means is you're going to be uh
setting aside 1 000 of the 10 000 for
your baby step one starter emergency
fund and that's going to leave you with
9 000 to throw at the remaining 37
which by my math takes you down to what
28
correct and how much do you guys make a
year james
uh 45 000. 45 and do you guys have any
kids
i've got two little girls and we live
with our in-laws right now so we've got
about thirteen thousand dollars we've
been putting into our savings each month
thirteen thousand
oh sorry no thirteen hundred times oh i
was like man that's incredible let's get
rid of these student loans okay so
i would love to hear about 13 000 to put
in every month so your expenses must be
really low
yeah so we just have like our basic
stuff we don't have any car loans or
credit card debt or anything like that
it's just student loans
yeah i mean can you can either one of
you maybe take on a side job and try to
get a little more income while we get
these student loans paid off
yeah so we just paid off
probably about five thousand dollars in
medical debt i drive ubereats on the
side
and so that's really helped with that
and so now all that can start going
towards student loan debt as well so
james what do you guys do if you're
making 45 household you and your wife
what do you guys do
um so i actually work in sales and
account management for a company here in
salt lake my wife doesn't work right now
just some stuff that she's going through
right now she was a school teacher
we also were on a waiting list for a
sweat equity um home building program
and they just recommended because she's
not going to work once we get into it
that she wasn't necessarily working when
we got into that program what's that
program about
so essentially it's it's a sweat equity
program where about 10 families get
together
um through a non-profit and we actually
build each other's homes
it allows us to get into a home for
about two hundred thousand on a mortgage
for four hundred thousand dollar home
so it's just a good she can't do you
have to be at a certain income in order
to qualify for that
yeah yeah so we'd still be within the
income but they said that she won't work
when she's up there and they just didn't
recommend that she worked when we were
on that james yeah i don't know i'm not
liking this i don't like the fact that
you have to limit your income i know
this this feels odd to me
yeah i know but james you can get a 200
you can get an incredible mortgage or a
credible house that doesn't have to be a
400 000 house it what i'm feeling is
that you're you're yielding to other
people you're yielding to the government
to pay off the student loans you're
yielding to this program for a home
james you and your wife can do this you
guys are smart you can be self
self-sufficient you can
rent for a little bit move out of your
in-laws let her work
you guys get this income up wipe off the
student loan save up for a down payment
i mean y'all could live the american
dream you can do this yes i'm getting
exciting just here excited just hearing
rachel talk about this stuff you can do
this man put the ball back in your
course yes don't limit yourself don't
let me your income don't wait on the
government take control bring up that
income get rid of these student loans
live life on your terms this is the
ramsay show